but not like yeah I hey because I I had
the point when I needed to make the
decision okay cuz I I did YouTube when I
was 17 and then I did it throughout uni
basically I graduated and I was like
okay do I pursue this as a job or do I
do I do I do a normal job and do a
nine-to-five job and I remember when I
finished uni like it was unheard of to
basically make money off anime content
you know what I mean anime was like I
was at the top of basically you'd like
the Annie Tube sphere at that point and
I had like barely a hundred thousand
subscribers and like I wasn't monetized
yeah yeah yeah this was this was like
no because monetization back then was
like a really right yeah it was like a
really new thing and me being a nanny
tuber like who the [ __ ] gets monetize on
foot on YouTube for anime right so it
was like I had basically no revenue
streams that I could basically point to
because I saw you know vloggers and
other people making money but I was like
like I have nowhere near the numbers
that are that are capable of make
generating income so I made the
conscious decision to like just quit
YouTube and do do a full-time job and in
that time Jerry rose up so quickly
passed it's so quickly and and and I'm
like holy what the [ __ ] he's getting
over like 500k viewers what subscribers
what is this what is this whoa it's a
swanky hair I know he's newly promote
protein for protein jelly and basically
it was in that two years or like two and
a half years that I was gone that I I've
already saw an audience in the anime
sphere that I never had seen before and
I was like holy [ __ ] maybe maybe I could
make something on this and I remember it
was Sydney that actually convinced me to
be like God just shut up you'll be
talking about this for too [ __ ] long
quit your job and just do YouTube
account I was like fine I'll like I'll
give it a go
but you know a good job at the bbc2
doing anime that's quite a big leap
right yeah if people aren't in that
position with a good job and then they
moved out I mean do your job at the BBC
no I was going to quit either way so the
reasoning was I was like looking for a
new job anyway so I was like this is the
perfect chance do something risky with
my life and basically because I had this
thing on YouTube ages ago like I didn't
even know if anyone still watched me or
whatever so it was nerve-racking coming
back to YouTube right because I went to
that you know like I said like the top
of the you the a Nietzsche game which
wasn't really that big looking back but
it was it was still like gone from that
to almost completely irrelevant so I
didn't know if anyone still remembered
me or anything like that two years is a
long [ __ ] time in YouTube terms and
so it was so [ __ ] nerve-wracking
having to choose to come back to YouTube
I remember the conversation with my
parents when I said I'm gonna quit the
BBC and do YouTube to talk about anime
they were not happy they were not happy
at all they they tried everything to
convince me to like okay you want to
quit the BBC that's fine we understand
just just just find another job gone and
basically the only way I was able to
convince them was I had like I made the
decision like half a year before so I
had saved up all this money in that time
I'd done nothing then didn't really go
out or do anything I just put it all
into my savings I'm like look mom and
dad I've got all this money my savings
just let me do this for half a year if
it doesn't work out I will quit YouTube
straight away remember the video when
you came back because we're like pretty
big news in the energy world where it's
like Gaea who's like like super og in
the anjikuni everybody knows who he is
even with the two-year break he's coming
back right like when that happened and
your video you were you were like I'm
gonna do YouTube for a year and if it
doesn't work out during that time I'm
disappearing people we don't want it to
disappear let's give me this attention
and turn off now y'all that's a great
one
all of them if you don't support me
directly on a direct deposit to this
account